bonjour je m'appelle françoise et je ne
fume plus j'étais une grosse fumeuse
j'ai fumé pendant 30 ans j'en étais à 50
cigarettes par jour une vieille et
grosse fumeuse
je mets tout le temps tout le temps
maman brossant les dents
c'est dire je suis mais pour tenir bon
pour rester debout jeu mais pour me
détendre
vous savez la petite clope avant d'aller
dormir je suis mais pour ne pas dire
pour me taire
pour calmer mes colères pour me
conformer conformer je fumais quand
j'étais heureuse pour accompagner mes
reer je fumais quand j'étais triste pour
à ses jumelles à la clope
c'était ma copine je disais ma copine ma
compagne ma compagne des bons des
mauvais moments
ma béquille ma béquille à vivre je
fumais tranquillement je fumais je
fumais pour calmer mon stress
je me fabriquer une bulle une bulle de
fumée mon monde à moi hors du monde
coupez coupez je fumais m'étouffer je
fumais à chaque fois j'avais une émotion
avant même que l'émotion arrive une
émotion vite ou klopp une émotion vite
une clope
je fumais tout ça en moi vous savez je
le savais pas je ne savais pas
nécessaire je disais la cigarette mais
nécessaire je ne sais pas faire sans
fumée mois et puis et puis j'étais plus
en plus malade wap grave
petit coup de ventoline une taffe petit
coup de ventoline de taf
t'écoutes ventoline tiens on rajoute un
oreiller dans le lit on dort semi 1,6 à
longeau on s'étouffe
et puis sté y ait dix ans quelques mois
auparavant j'avais perdu ma grand mère
j'étais très triste je me sentais comme
une petite fille abandonnée
alors le soir j'allais fumer ma dernière
cigarette sur la terrasse et je
regardais le ciel
je regardais les étoiles et je pense à
ma grand mère et je me disais j'irai
bientôt la rejoindre je me dis ça alors
je pensais aux dispositions à prendre
pour les enfants j'irai bientôt la
rejoindre j'avais 47 ans je préparais ma
mort j'avais 47 ans je savais que le
tabac était en train de me tuer et je ne
savais pas comment m'en débarrasser
j'avais 47 ans et je pensais comme une
femme de 80 ans et pourtant pourtant
j'avais envie de vivre
je vais désespérément énormément
immensément envie de suivre
alors alors j'ai dit j'arrête j'arrête
et là tout le monde a rigolé la famille
les enfants les collègues les amis
aulas françoise la clope est aussi une
histoire d'amour à tout tout tout à
françoise combien de fois tu nous a fait
le coup
1 comme une fois d'arrêter comme une
fois tu tiens combien une demi journée
une journée deux jours dans quel état en
plus un
combien de fois plein de fois je vais
arrêter plein de fois toutefois le
parfait manuel du des fumeurs solitaire
je le connaissais par coeur
j'avais même eu en prime le petit guide
spécial des idées reçues sur le sevrage
tabagique
vous savez les petites idées là qui vous
plombe bien qui vous font reprendre une
clope
je m'étais mis un patch énorme avait dit
une fille comme toi t'es pas au courant
mais la nicotine c'est une saloperie
ça donne des soucis cardiaques du bol
que tu sois pas enceinte je te raconte
pas des formations chez le bébé n'était
pas au courant
j'avais utilisé un hymne à l'heure et
j'étais amblas en gare de rennes
tranquille avec mon hymne à l'heure et
là il y avait un jeune homme hilare qui
était venu me voir madame madame madame
il m'avait tapoter sur l'épaule madame
oui vous avez oublié votre type de temps
taxe dans votre bouche puis puis paraît
il paraît que j'étais beaucoup moins
sympathique beaucoup moins rigolote et
beaucoup plus stressé quand je fumais
pas aller françoise vian on boit fume
une clope
allez juste une une petite danse pas ça
qui va te faire du mal et moi et moi je
faisais comment je faisais comment alors
alors j'ai demandé de l'aide
j'ai été voir une tabacologue elle m'a
prescrit tout ce qu'il fallait en
substituts nicotiniques pour calmer la
dépendance physique ya pas qu elle mais
ça y est bien
elle m'a soutenue elle m'a accompagné
alors je me suis connecté sur internet
et j'ai été sur un forum
et là j'ai créé un blog mois franck oise
47 ans droguée dans l'un des premiers
articles je racontais que j'étais assise
dans mon bureau et que je me balançais
d'avant en arrière comme une gamine
autistes tellement j'étais en manque
hélas une personne a répondu je n'ai
jamais relu je ne sais pas qui c'est
mais je sais qu'il s'appelait milk et il
a écrit une phrase qui a changé pour moi
le cours des choses
il a écrit franck oise l'adefim est un
apprentissage attend un apprentissage un
apprenti
h ça veut dire que moi la came de she
came je pouvais apprendre
alors j'ai appris jours à jour
pas à pas j'ai appris à défaire les uns
après les autres les liens puissants
intime entre moi et le tabac j'ai viré
la clope festive la clope amoureuse la
clope j'ai faim la clope j'en peux plus
la clope suivent pas se fatiguer lac
l'objet du boulot à finir la cloche
foutez moi la paix la clau mon monde à
moi une a8 je les ai viré 500 pages 500
pages d'apprentissage j'ai appris plein
de choses
j'ai appris que la des films c'est du
temps qu'il faut se laisser du temps
pour arrêter de fumer on a fumé des
années j'ai appris que les dés fume
c'est de la dentelle on s'en fout de la
méthode
l'important c'est d'y arriver j'ai même
appris que j'avais trois cerveaux 1 2 3
6 6 3 cerveau moi je disais j'ai un
flamby à la place du cerveau
tellement j'étais fatigué de ce truc
d'arrêter de fumer
je vais un cerveau automatique le chef à
bord
celui qui appuyée sur les boutons
respire mange dort fume plus fumer comme
un acte automatique
c'est donc celui là qui m'avait fait
penser quand j'avais pensé - arrêter de
fumer
mon dieu mais quand je gère pour
respirer j'avais pensé sans vrai j'avais
un deuxième cerveau le raisonnable celui
qui regardaient les paquets de
cigarettes fumées tuent cancer emphysème
stérilité à mourir celui qui vous fait
dire ouais je vais arrêter je te promets
je te promet d'ailleurs demain je fume
des clopes tu peux les compter 10 papus
servolex fait peur il fout la trouille
et quand on a la trouille ans fument et
puis il y avait un troisième servent
le magnifique le cerveau du coeur de
cerveau affectif
celui qui te dit vas-y tu peux esaïe le
cerveau du désir et ce cerveau là il
allait m'apporter quelque chose
d'extraordinaire quelque chose de
merveilleux
l'espoir l'espoir
un espoir que moi j'allais partager avec
des centaines d'autres qui faisait le
même chemin que moi et qui avaient
besoin d' aide parce que quand on arrête
de fumer
on a besoin des deux arrêter de fumer
c'est pas que arrêter de fumer c'est
changer profondément changé le tabac il
n'investit pas que nos organismes
il va coloniser s'immiscer dans chacune
de nos émotions dans chacune des sphères
de nos existences
alors quand on arrête on est paumé
on est fatigué on ne sait plus on chiale
on s'énerve on stresse on n'a plus ses
repères on est perdu alors on se rend
compte de tous les petits arrangements
qu'on avait fait avec nos réalités en
fumant une clope
alors on se rend compte du tout ce qu'on
avait caché à coups de mégots alors mois
françoise j'ai dit les mots que j'avais
tout fait avec le tabac j'ai dit que je
ne pouvais pu te faire des journées 10
heures de boulot j'ai dit quand je
n'étais pas d'accord au début un peu
n'importe comment s'asseoir en vrac les
mots puis de plus en plus fermement
quand on arrête de fumer on retrouve
quelque chose qu'il estime de soi
et puis et puis on se dit que la vie
notre vie elle vaut la peine or ça peut
sembler un peu ridicule de dire qu'une
vie vaut la peine
mais je vous assure que moi quand je me
suis dit tu sais tu avoues vie vaut la
peine loi qui fut même avis à petit feu
et bien jouer sur scène une sacrée
émotion
vous voyez tout ça ça chamboule je
raconte pas le nombre de fois où je me
suis retrouvé dans les toilettes à mon
travail
pleurer je disais le torchon il m'en
faut des torchons parce que les
mouchoirs ça suffit plus je pleurais des
sceaux delame
je savais même pas pourquoi mais je
savais une chose c'est est que le tabac
ne les assécher plus vous voyez j'ai
appris plein de choses et je me suis dit
qu'il fallait construire un lieu où ces
apprentissages là un lieu où l'amitié la
fraternité l'entr'aide pouvait exister
un lieu on pourrait se dire un lieu où
on pourrait exister un lieu où la parole
seraient libres un lieu où les gens
seraient ce lieu ils devaient proche des
gens et les gens ils sont où ils sont
sur les réseaux sociaux
ils sont sur facebook facebook les fakes
news
l'aefo compte la haine les arnaqueurs
les selphy regardez moi regardez moi
regardez moi tellement retour témoin
quand je me déplace à des colloques ou
quand je vois des chercheurs quand ils
me disent vous êtes sur facebook
facebook
ah je vois je vois
bah oui on voit on voit on voit même
très bien 25000 personnes
un fumeur sur mille en france dans un
groupe fermé protégé où la parole est
libre
80 bénévoles qui se relaient jour et
nuit pour accueillir accompagner
conseiller
ap apporter de l'aide et de l'entr'aide
du j'ai appris nous sommes passés au
nous apprenons nous apprenons nous
apprenons que quand on prend une clope
c'est pas un drame
il s'appelle une peau de banane on dit
je me suis pris une peau de banane
je rencontre un bananier je me suis
paumé dans une bananeraie et là vous
avez 10 15 20 50 personnes qui arrivent
et qui vous disent à temps il s'est
passé quoi on va t'aider
on est là t'inquiète pas on continue
avec toi on apprend que juste une la
petite copine avec juste un paquet qui
te copain avec juste une cartouche et
que quand rechute on n'est pas nul
contrairement ce que disent les gens on
a appris que chaque pas est un pas vers
la réussite que chaque essai est un
apprentissage
on apprend à dire autrement nos émotions
on apprend à poster un message plutôt
que de fumer une clope
on apprend à parler de nez histoire de
vie donné histoire avec le tabac et on
sait que ceux qui nous lisent ne vont
pas nous juger
ils sont à même de nous soutenir on
apprend les réponse au pourquoi du
sevrage
pourquoi j'ai des boutons pourquoi je
suis constipé pourquoi j'ai la peau plus
jolie trouve pas que les plus jolies
pourquoi pourquoi j'ai une érection
matinale plus importante pourquoi je
laisse un plus plus gros pourquoi nous
apprenons nous sommes même fêté moi
perso je suis poulette de diamant
quand on est à un mois de déchu mme on
est culture de coton ça peut faire
sourire mais quand tu arrives un mois
sans fumée et que tu à 100 150 200 300
personnes qui te disent yes
tu l'as fait à moins que des fouilles tu
l'as fait bravo et que vous êtes
l'europe hutin sur les feuilles je les
fais les faits gelée de favre à manger
pas fumer pendant un mois et tout le
monde vous applaudit et qu'à côté il est
quelqu'un qui dit là j'ai une clope
devant moi je viens engueulé avec mon
patron
mais je la ferai pas je ne fumerai pas
parce que mon pioupious je le veux et je
serai plus de coton nous apprenons
ensemble à prendre de plus en plus
confiance en notre capacité à réussir à
prendre de plus en plus confiance en
notre valeur à nous je ne suis plus
seule
nous ne sommes plus seuls nous apprenons
ensemble à lever les rideaux de fumée
en parlant en disant en étouffant plus
la richesse de nos existences
je voudrais vous raconter je voudrais
vous dire vraiment tous les visages qui
se cache derrière mes mots je voudrais
vous parler de bernard qui est arrivé il
venait de subir une opération du coeur
il avait une valve et ils disaient vous
voyez cette valve c'est tout ce qu'ils
on reste propre dans mon corps je veux
que ça reste propre et qui sont jours
après nous dit la vie est belle je
voudrais vous parler de jaja qui est
handicapée qui peut plus bouger de sa
chambre et qui s'est acheté une tablette
pour fêter les anniversaires de ses
copains et ses copines tous les jours
magnifique fenêtre sur le monde
je voudrais vous dire à quel point on
rigole je voudrais vous dire à quel
point c'est important d'avoir un monde
où on peut parler dans nos vies on parle
peu ou parfois on ne parle plus je
voudrais vous dire à quel point c'est
essentiel d'avoir un endroit où on peut
frapper et où la porte s'ouvre quelle
que soit l'heure où le jour vous êtes
accueillis vous êtes aidez vous êtes
soutenu
nous on s'appelle la famille on
s'appelle les copains et les copines
non on parle tous les jours on partage
notre expérience on partage nos
découvertes on partage ses émotions
on partage notre moral aux nos petits
bonheurs nous fêté du jour nos humeurs
on partage nos apprentissages
quand nous rencontrons tous on se
serrent dans les bras on partage
ensemble plus que le sevrage nous quand
on se rencontre on poursuit la
conversation de la veille
parce que tous ensemble tous ensemble
pas à pas je rajoute on se reconstruit
la des films comme un chemin vers soi
même la diffusion comme un chemin vers
la vie moi je m'appelle françoise j'ai
aujourd'hui l'âge qu'avait mon père
quand il est mort du tabac je suis libre
je suis vivante je ne fume plus
[Applaudissements]